married so you shouldn't be having sex
with someone you're not married to in a
culture where people are having sex
outside of marriage where they're living
together when they're not married you're
correct that uh it doesn't seem from
like a material perspective that
anything is really added to the
relationship by entering into a legal
Union with each other well even when you
look at like you know Purity and youth
like men don't even get that anymore out
of marriage like in the UK the average
age of first marriage for a girl is 31.
and why like Purity like what percent of
women do you think we're virgins in
1920.
there's been surveys done and many more
women I mean you don't know like people
can lie but there's like 85 percent of
women
um did not like they said their virgins
on their wedding day like what is that
today so what what does a guy get from
Marriage yeah so he doesn't get Purity
doesn't get youth um now she has the
power to take I mean but that's that is
more of a traditionalist argument that
doesn't I don't think matters
materialistically or um
what I'm saying is there are certainly
people who care about purity and all
that stuff I don't think the average
person thinks like is my wife pure but a
lot of guys probably do yeah what I'm
saying is you go to a guy and say Hey
you know that long-term relationship
you're in yes why don't you get married
okay why well if you do you open up the
door to losing half of everything you
own if things go bad and nothing else
changes what does the woman get the
woman gets half your stuff if she
decides to leave at any point well but
this is also the point right the left
Marxist they they hate marriage and they
hate the family so people look at how
the culture has been oriented and they
look at these no-fault divorce laws and
they say oh my goodness there's no point
in even getting married anymore well
that was by Design like the entire
purpose was to dissuade people from
wanting to get married that was the long
game that was the long game and make it
and so I think our marriage is okay
exactly right because if if sex before
marriage is on the table then you can
have that without committing to a person
I mean what are most men gonna choose
even if you don't have these wacky
diverse
although divorce in America side I find
it weird to say that sex before marriage
is bad because like if you have if you
don't if you have sex or girl and you
don't like it but you don't know that
until after you're married that'd be
horrible well sex isn't tryouts right
and she's a person and you're a person
and that's an act that creates human
people and it'll create a person even if
you didn't think the sex was uh all that
great I think that two people
who are married should should try uh to
communicate with one another so that
they can you know meet each other's
needs in illicit way and uh I think
we've created so many problems with no
fault divorce in this sexual Evolution
and sex outside of marriage to say that
you know a solution to that problem
isn't good enough because it might
interfere with some people's ability to
have sexual pleasure doesn't really
convince me well and it's not even about
like moral like good or bad it's like
what outcomes does what outcomes does
this have and like the studies show that
the best outcomes are from two people
that are both virgins
but the best outcomes of marriage yeah
and marriage satisfaction how would you
know if the sex was bad if you didn't
have sex with anyone else exactly that's
the same exact argument feminists make
they're like wow that must suck
condemning your life to bad sex because
you live this puritanical way yeah yeah
okay yeah but again that's that's a
horrible way of viewing sex it's a
horrible way of ignoring other people
and well it's not just that ignorance is
bliss it's that there are some things
you have no need to know but right like
it doesn't there is some information
that's not going to make you happier
there are a lot of things that all of us
could know that we don't want to know
because it would make us miserable
that's a five-minute orgasm would be
awesome like if you could have non-stop
orgasms with your wife like it's just
you could do like two hours of tantrics
do you think with sex outside of
marriage that's happening for people
because the studies show that people
rate lower marital satisfaction rates
when they've had more sexual partners
prior to marriage have you ever have you
ever watched any romantic comedy yeah
like the Trope is that the women are
always unsatisfied like the guys are in
it for a one night stand it's wham bam
thank you ma'am and they leave well and
also that not to get I mean since we're
already having an adult conversation
here they have done studies with Rams
right so this is something that I
learned when I was looking into the
effects that pornography has in the
brain and how men will seek out novelty
and they found
with these Muse that they were studying
that men finished more quickly with a
newer partner okay so exactly so I I
don't think I have to elaborate any
further on the implications of that it's
not just that I think that if you have
two people who care about each other
it's likely going to be better between
them than a guy who's like can I get
this woman in the closet for a few
minutes yeah there is I think there's a
problem of chasing the orgasm that's
that's I think my mom would be like your
dad just he's obsessed with sex oh my
God he just loves that and I'm like well
okay maybe I gotta not do that then but
like on the other side it is pretty epic
you know like a good orgasm is like what
I don't think anything else in the world
can compete with that
uh maybe not a good meal I mean maybe a
good meal if you're hungry I'm sure
everybody in the comment is going to say
the same face they're gonna say the face
seeing the face of your child for the
first time oh yeah good point Ian
doesn't have kids I was actually
thinking that today raising kids is far
superior like having a family as far as
just just being with people and you're
better off in a committed relationship
with someone who you know won't just up
and leave and take everything and your
kids from you and that's the other thing
too with with no fault divorce you have
no guarantee you get to keep your kids
there's just like the family has been
completely destroyed and there is a
tremendous risk in having kids because
they could just take your kids from you
and then destroy your life there's only
11 states that have automatic 50 50
custody out of 50. so it's like if it's
50 it's DNA why doesn't he get 50
custody off the bat well there was a
there was a story at Wisconsin where a
guy who wasn't even the Father the woman
claimed he was and the courts ordered
him to pay child support because she
listed him as the father and the DNA
proved he wasn't there we don't care kid
needs a day wow yeah what do you think
Pearl what do you think is like a
solution to this you know Vault divorce
situation oh I think we should ban
divorce
ban it completely exactly like what if a
guy's beating his wife if he's beating
his wife I think I think there's an
exception to every rule but I don't
think that makes the rule um but you
know what you know what else do you know
and Alice they don't talk about when
they look at one-sided abuse women hit
men more than men hit women so it's the
women that are beating their husbands
more than the husbands are beating their
wife one it's one-sided because the
majority of abuse cases is mutual and
the other thing they don't talk about
and I'm so tired of this on the show
these girls will come on and say I was
abused I was abused and I used to just
believe women right because it's like
and it's kind of a sensitive it's kind
of awkward in the room and someone's
like oh I was abused but it's like if
you're bringing it up on the show I'm
gonna ask you questions right you
clearly want you talked about it so and
then I would ask questions and I'd
realize these girls were not talking
about the part they had to play in the
abuse I'll give you an example one girl
she says I was abused so I say okay what
happened how how because I'm thinking
like the average guy can beat me the
hell I'd be dead like that and I'm I
deadlift 300 pounds I'm a semi-pro
athlete I had Pro contracts in the fall
I'm six foot like I'm pretty built for
for check right and I'm still saying the
average guy can beat me up so I'm like
okay if he was beating you like that
like where is where are your injuries
right so I asked her what happened she
says well he pushed me like he pushed me
down the stairs or something like that
and I was like okay well why like what
led up to this and you know come to find
out
this girl wouldn't leave so she refused
to use trespassing on this guy's house
wouldn't leave and then he pushes her
out of the house that's abuse
that's abuse is that actually with what
he did was was that legal to push her
out of the house did he push her down
the stairs though because that's
different from like trying to move
someone from your problem that's what
she was trying to do that's what he was
like I don't yeah
well don't push people downstairs yeah
yeah I don't think he meant to like the
way she was saying is like she was like
she wouldn't leave so what are you
supposed to do she now you could call
the cops but I'm saying it wasn't this
like you probably thought you got to
call the police yeah yeah because
because you have to protect yourself but
my point is she didn't talk about like
my point isn't like was it abuse wasn't
it abuse my point is women don't talk
about the part they have to play in it
yeah so you know you know what I do I
just I would just go in my room lock the
door call the police say I gotta break
him that's it I mean yeah yeah but it is
like a person who enters your property
without your permission and I'd say
there's an ongoing burglar I've locked
myself in my room you guys can deal with
it because what will happen is if you
try to physically remove her and the
cops show up she'll say help help I'm
being abused right you will get arrested
right so just go in your room lock the
door I'm not saying run and cower I'm
saying just separate yourself from this
person and then call the police and be
like please come burglar in progress
then they'll come in and find the lady
screaming and ranting and you'll be like
I am in the other room door's locked man
all right well and the other thing is
like as I was saying before what they
did um and this is more um pertaining to
the UK um not the us but I know some
states have similar laws to this they've
basically expanded the definition of
abuse to include things like coercive
control Financial abuse
um and they have like a list of like
five to I think ten and it's a point
system so basically what happens is if
you like maybe two times he said you
were financially abused
um three times you you were coercively
controlled like they even say they were
graped like early on in the relationship
or something like that even though they
would like stay for later and if you get
like I don't know maybe it's seven
points out of ten like then that's like
considered abusive we have grapes
growing on the property this is crazy no
joke you gotta check them out like
actual grapevines with and you can see
the grapes coming in careful but if you
eat the skin before washing it off
there's a lot of like okay apparently
you gotta freeze them or something
they're called Frost grapes I don't know
anything about it yeah I had a similar
situation yeah well I didn't know if you
could say that on the show you could say
grape on on YouTube well I don't know
but so like when it comes to abuse like
if it's a genuinely abusive situation
sure like we divorc fine fine but like I
think it's more of the exception than
the rule because even people that work
at abuse like centers will tell you the
majority of abuse cases they're both
abusing each other so it's not just
one-sided so at that point it's just
like a toxic relationship maybe they
should like take some time apart I wanna
I wanna come back to a lot of the
subject because we as many of you know
talk
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible